right welcome to portugal um what an
amazing place and trust me i've had an
extraordinary week
i'm on this amazing pig farm and they're
producing the black pig poco preto
and it is just one of the best pigs
anywhere in the world
um that's it there we'll use this
incredible skirt
okay that's the rump as well but
just a very simple sort of almost like
bacon and eggs but these eggs look
they're blue eggs so it's like
black pork blue eggs beautiful look at
the marbling that
and the last three months the life of
the pigs here they get fed these
incredible acorns
they've got a spa here for the pigs
trust me the best kept pigs in the world
happy pigs delicious pigs
but first little rinse their hands
start off with the vegetables the onions
slice them down
beautiful and then from there get these
little pedro peppers
again slice them whole in
that's got a really nice bit of heat and
then it's some beautiful
red pepper the idea here of course
is literally just frying all this up and
it's the sort of
the vegetable base for the bacon and the
eggs
alongside that okay some beautiful
butter mushrooms it's nice and quite
thick the mushrooms
from there a little touch of olive oil
in in she goes with olive oil
i'm gonna fry the eggs in butter and
olive oil
but i'm gonna cook the eggs really
slowly
okay so i'm gonna get the oil nice and
warm in
get the butter in there now so it starts
to sort of froth
and i'll crack the eggs into there but
first start frying off the veg
now lift up the pan
beautiful there she goes
now this tree here this tree here is 500
years old
and it produces some of the best cork
anywhere on the world
and around has got all these little
acorn trees and that's where the pigs
come through and they feed
especially across their last months of
their welfare right off all the veg
beautifully done
once that butter starts to melt okay i'm
gonna get the eggs in there
and just crack them on a nice flat
surface
so as not to break nice and carefully
there you go
one again
two and the secret here is cooking
really nice and slowly
the butter's nice and warm okay i've got
enough butter in there to make them go
nice and frothy
and cook the whites as well keep that
nice and stable
a little touch of pepper a little touch
of salt
and then look i'm just going to put them
back on the side of the grill
nice and slowly just there salt
and pepper in okay look at that
beautiful
now for after veg slowly cook the eggs
okay the flavor
of this pork will literally bring you to
your knees look at the eggs now
that's why i put the butter in early so
the butter goes over the egg white
starts frothing up and it cooks the eggs
slowly but i'm going to show you a nice
little trick
get a really nice color on those
vegetables like that okay
as that butter starts frothing up okay
you take it off the heat again
okay literally off
touch more oil in the veg nice
now look at the eggs what you do now
you've got that nice and fluffy
it's going to help cook the top of that
egg you take them off
and you let them sit here literally
i don't want the eggs blistering and
bursting everywhere it's a beautiful
flavoured egg
but look bring the temperature up as
that butter starts frothing take it off
and you'll see them slowly cook there
okay the table's a little bit uneven so
just lift up with a little fork there
and keep them nice and flat
now vegetables look at those
as they start to break down get some
color on them
no color no flavor and more importantly
i want all that water out the vegetables
on now for the skirt here we go so you
take the skirt
i'm going to slice nice beautiful
almost like sort of slivers
of this incredible amazing
look at that that is stunning
don't worry about the fat i'll show you
why because you start to rend that down
and look at that it's so beautiful
now season that beautifully and get that
on the grill
okay now
slide that over okay
and on the grill goes there
beautiful vegetables sweated off
beautifully
as that bacon is grilling a nice little
season
beautiful salt and pepper
turn that over
beautiful
now i've got a little trick
from jurgen he's going to let me brand
my own
slice of bacon i'm gonna put that on
there
and literally
fingers crossed it's gonna be a
gr bacon and there we go
beautiful extra flavor
and look at that amazing put that in
there
now that bacon literally needs
90 seconds okay turn the board over
so we've got raw and then look
get your bacon out
okay beautiful now
when we come to serve this look
that goes on there two nice bits
these little bits here what you do
is just very very quickly slice them up
it's so tender
keep one nice piece of bacon for the
hero and then you get your vegetables
all that bacon in there and you mix that
up
and that's going to sit on top
to serve beautifully season
a nice generous amount
of the vegetables from there
i'm going to very carefully select my
egg
so nice when they cook slowly because
they'll just literally slide onto the
spoon
there's no runny egg white anywhere lift
that up
sit that on top be useful
and then take your bacon next to it
that has to be one of the
poshest happiest bacon eggs anywhere on
the planet
happy pigs delicious bacon
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted
then please watch on catch up on disney
plus